I can see how my feathers are ruffled
and my posture changes and that is the
power of makeup that is the power of
beauty it's empowering
drew Barrymore speaking exclusively with
et at beautycon la the 43 year old
makeup guru opened up about her
cosmetics line flower beauty and how she
hopes it inspires her daughters olive
and Frankie olive had beads and little
dots everywhere and she was she's just
so artistic about it and I had such
pride because I was a little girl
growing up in a makeup chair and
watching women empower themselves in a
makeup trailer and walk in tired and
walk out feeling amazing and that's what
makeup does it's transformative how do
you manage to do all this to be a
working woman to be a mom and find time
to date I know you send the pasture on
the apps' do you still do the apps what
do you know I got off it was fun to try
though it's like I've been working out
there in the public since I was young so
that myth of the blind date eluded me
and I always wanted to do it so that was
kind of like a dating app for me but
then it's not blind on my side so it
just kind of I don't know it doesn't
work but I know just still single
you know we've do friends set you up all
the time no none of my friends ever set
me up where is the friend setting people
up I I think I just have the same old
friends for so long we're all in such a
rhythm we don't even think like that
speaking of friends there's one who's
always had Drew's back I know Cameron
Diaz is someone who's always so
supported you my best friend my sister
we're like more than best friends she's
my sister we're very honest with each
other we push each other and we've had
you know the majority of our lives spent
side by side really going through what
real life is good morning angels good
morning charlie
Charlie's Angels one of your most iconic
movies getting a rebooted which could we
see you make a cameo viewed thoughts on
the Catherine it's just something about
Charlie's Angels that make men
women so happy and it's so positive and
so if they keep that alive you know in
this new iteration it's just going to be
great and that's kicking your
[Music]